100 tage krieg putins krieg gegen die
ukraine gegen die menschen in der
ukraine
sie werden getötet von putins truppen
verletzt vertrieben ihre häuser und
wohnungen werden zerstört irland wird
ihnen gestohlen 100 tage dauert dieses
verbrechen mittlerweile an und vom
ersten tag an waren unsere reporter vor
ort und darüber zu berichten und sie
haben dinge erlebt die sie nie mehr
vergessen werden
[Musik]
100 tage krieg 100 tage leid und
zerstörung
100 tage in denen unsere reporter bilder
gesehen haben die sie ihr leben lang
begleiten werden
[Musik]
bestimmte bilder die ich im krieg
gesehen haben drei monaten wenig
berichtet habe werde ich nie vergessen
zum beispiel das was in guca passiert
ist dort wo menschen hingerichtet wurden
zivilisten die auf der straße lagen
neben dem fahrrad mit kartoffelsäcken
die sie gerade geholt haben also ganz
klar zivilisten und diese menschen tot
auf der straße zu sehen und so klar zu
sehen was putin und was die russische
armee dort in der ukraine tut dass es
etwas was einen auch wochen und monate
danach noch verfolgt
dramatische szenen erlebt auch unser
reporter peter held zu beginn des
krieges in kiew also dieses diese panik
die an diesem bahnhof in kiew entstanden
ist das waren so die ersten szenen wo
man gemerkt hat ok wo geht der krieg in
das war ganz dramatisch weil die leute
dort zum ersten mal gemerkt haben jetzt
wird es wirklich eng wir sind da morgens
um acht uhr hingekommen da war der
bahnhof noch relativ leer zwei stunden
später standen 1000 auf den bahnsteigen
es kam zu dramatischen szenen die
personen die menschen die familien haben
teilweise ihre kinder über die anderen
personen drüber hinweg getragen damit
sie ihm die züge kommen
das schicksal von irina berührt paul
ronzheimer ganz besonders
irina habe ich an einem abend getroffen
in der metro wo sie gegen putin
demonstriert hat wo sie gesagt hat
dieser krieg muss aufhören wir wollen
frieden und am nächsten tag habe ich die
nachricht bekommen dass irina eben von
einer rakete getroffen wurde im gesicht
zerfetzt zum glück hat sie überlebt sie
würde dann aus geflogen wenn man
niemanden gesehen hat der mutige
demonstriert und am nächsten tag hört
wie genau diese person das erlebt hat
was erinnerten hat dass es definitiv
etwas was sein sind
vor den toren kiews trifft peter hell
auf eine gruppe ukrainischer verteidiger
die ihm besonders im gedächtnis blieb
und was daneben in dieser situation auch
so emotional war für uns auch dass die
männer im bunker gesessen haben quasi im
gefecht stellen und davor oder an diesem
bunker hatten die kinder bilder für ihre
väter gemalt aus grundschulen die ihn
ebenso ein bisschen freude bereiten
sollen und sie erinnern sollten wofür
sie überhaupt dort in diesen schützen
ständen stehen und ihr land verteidigen
immer wieder trifft paul ronzheimer auch
den ukrainischen präsidenten volumina
seelands die
ich habe präsidentin lenski dreimal
während des krieges getroffen das erste
mal im märz und dort bin ich in einen
präsidenten gebäude gekommen wo kein
licht mehr war wo samstag links und
rechts an wo große nervosität herrschte
weil man immer noch davon ausgegangen
war dass der lenski getötet werden
könnte das sozusagen russische sniper
dort in der nähe sind und wir saßen
gemeinsam auf den treppen dieses
präsidenten gebäude ist das natürlich
völlig ungewöhnlich ist für einen
ukrainischen präsidenten einem dort zu
sitzen und er hat dort das gezeigt was
sie im gesamten krieg ausgemacht hat
eine wahnsinnige kommunikative stärke
nämlich eine sehr große klarheit eine
bestimmtheit und auch forderungen
gegenüber dem westen
es sind vor allem die leiden der kinder
die unsere reporter besonders berühren
in einem krankenhaus trifft peter hell
auf ein vater und sein sohn die von
einem russischen scharfschützen verletzt
wurden
beide lagen dort völlig paralysiert
eigentlich der vater hat die hand ist
jungs gehalten und der arzt erzählte uns
dass tage zuvor die familie quasi ins
kreuz wurden zu dieser von russischen
scharfschützen geraten ist und die
mutter wurde vor den augen des ehemanns
und des sohns des achtjährigen miroslav
zweimal in die brust geschossen und das
ist ein schicksal was für 100 hunderte
für tausende steht in diesem krieg das
dort zivilisten
vollkommen
unnötig vollkommen barbarisch quasi ins
visier dieser raketen dieser
scharfschützen geraten auch wenn man
sieht dass es sich um zivilisten handelt
wurde drauf geschossen und das macht
einen schon sehr betroffen und das zeigt
eben dass dort eine komplette enthemmung
auch stattgefunden hat fernab von
militärischen zielen hinzu zivil
100 tage krieg unter tage leid und
zerstörung 100 tage die die welt niemals
vergessen wird einen ausblick für die
nächsten wochen ist
das wenn es genug waffen gibt die
ukraine sich verteidigen wird können
also diese wille ist weiterhin vorhanden
aber
wenn es nicht genügend waffen nicht
genügend artillerie nicht genügend
flugabwehr nicht genügend raketensysteme
gibt es die russen langsam aber stetig
vorrücken und den gesamten sommers ein
nehmen könnten also ich glaube
tatsächlich die nächsten wochen sind
krieg sein scheinen putin wird
weitermachen putin setzt dann auf die
zeit und ich befürchte dass wenn der
winter einkehrt wenn der boden wieder
hart ist wenn die ukrainischen einheiten
keine deckung haben durch wälder oder
durch anderen schutz werden sie im
winter versuchen wieder erneut zu
starten angriffe zu starten und ich
befürchte dass sie versuchen auch wieder
nach kiew reinzukommen ich glaube dass
butscher ganz sicher und die bilder der
leichten ich tatsächlich meinen leben
lang begleiten werden aber ich werde
auch zurückgehen in die ukraine um
weiter zu berichten denn ich glaube es
ist wichtig dass weiterhin reporter vor
ort
ja und im moment ist unser reporter
brand strietzel in kharkiv ja und also
100 tage krieg wenn du mit den menschen
spricht in diesem umkämpften gebieten
was glauben sie denn wie lange dieser
krieg noch anhalten wird
also ist ganz unterschiedlich mit dem
man spricht dann in welchen an welcher
ortschaft einstellung sind dann beinahe
siegesgewiss dass niemand wird sagen ja
wir werden unsere heimat verlassen wir
werden hier
werden aufgeben und dergleichen
allerdings ist das
dorf einige fragen waren erlöse schon in
diesem jahr kämpften fast geschlossenen
kesseln die stimmung doch deutlich durch
definierte das hat man da so aus als das
bein steht wie hier in haag es sind wohl
gerade stehen anstatt die eigentlich
seit zwei wochen keinen beschluss mehr
hat erleiden müssen vor einer woche gab
es auf einmal ein
leben zu halten sind so vorsichtig
optimistisch darüber halten lange das
dauern wird man kann die gibt allerdings
keiner wird sogar ja noch du bist für
uns seit wochen schon in der ukraine
unterwegs gibt es ein schicksal eine
geschichte die sich ganz persönlich
besonders
[Applaus]
bei der etablierung eines jahres mit
dabei
diese liegt einige kilometer außerhalb
der großen gelände gelegen und zwar im
prinzip immer wieder ziel von physischen
dürfen also wir lachen wir in der
kampfzone
markierung diese bereit sich dann sehr
schwierig gestaltet wie der freiwillige
helfer sind westen gegangen unter
lebensgefahr sind von ihm wollen und
auch betriebs russischen beschuss und
als wir dann dort anfangen eigentlich
eine der letzten aktionen und sollten
wir uns auch straßen und brücken für
herausgebracht werden ich eigentlich
alles gut wie draußen konnten eingeladen
werden weil ich in eltern haben immer
wieder gefechte im hintergrund aber
nichts was jetzt was jetzt besonders
gefährdet gewesen allerdings kurz vor
dem abschluss lieder
überprüfungsaktionen gab sondern
russischen raketen angriffe mit
streumunition wird großflächig ist
eingesprungen und aufgefunden wird nicht
getroffen allerdings hat es zwei autos
der helfer stört bei diesen angriffen
auf bei der helfer wurden verletzt einer
davon schwer die junge der den beiden
eltern bei der kläger hat helfen wollte
und das auch regelmäßig behalten hat und
eines der stadt geleiten wo schenkel
akteure durch massiven blutverlust wir
sind dann mit einigen helfern auch mit
einem der verletzten nahm zum
krankenhaus
und
angekommen
[Applaus]
die todesnachricht
zu diesen russischen kriegsgefangenen
und zeigt in seiner wut beschmierten
hände und sagte schau dass das blut
meines kindes was euch willich einbinden
wir standen alle drum herum und
ganz schreckliche geschichte führen
danke dass du das mit uns geteilt hast
und danke dass du auch weiterhin vor ort
die stellung hält